like your dad's the big show it's been a  minute since I retired from wrestling so  I want to get in as much family time as  I can you kids so beautiful you talking  to mirror the belt you okay you two talk  [Music]  yeah it's [ __ ] up for a second we got  to lay down the law right away we my  daughters I'm not just some ex-wrestler  doesn't have a purpose I'm also a parent  I'll punish you  I don't know why this is so hard  you're doing up so fast  [Music]  we were a family I got you I don't know  what to say he just gives me dummy  [Music]  parent right I forget that sometimes  [Music]  [Music]  this is the big shopping show the  picture  this is my home you're my mom there's  nowhere else I want to be are you gonna  cry no yes but later when I'm in the  bath  [Music]  you